[Applauso]
[Musica]
la protagonista di questa storia non
sono io ma mia sorella Alice
perché dopo qualche tempo dalla mia
venuta al mondo è arrivata lei e con lei
non iniziamo parlando tra le tante cose
meravigliose che aveva il linguaggio
rimase sempre un po' il suo punto debole
iniziò a parlare tardi tardissimo e
rimase sempre un po' incomprensibile
agli altri non a me noi imparammo a
comunicare perfettamente Ci capivamo
perfettamente come al solito sorelle
sanno fare A tal punto che io divenne la
sua traduttrice per il mondo rendevo il
mondo più comprensibile a lei e rendevo
lei più comprensibile al mondo eravamo
due sorelle particolari diverse la
diversità in casa nostra
Furia sempre una normalità una normalità
Gioiosa leggera
a meno fino a che
non avvenne l'incontro scontro il
confronto con il mondo fuori la scuola
lo sport
dove la nostra diversità inizio ad
essere pesante a diventare pesante
e iniziarono lì le mie domande le mie
tante domande anche solo per rispondere
a lei quando mi chiedevagni così mi
chiama mia sorella perché mi guardano
e io iniziai a trovare le mie risposte
nei libri i libri divennero il mio luogo
ma tra le tante risposte mi davano
altrettante domande i tanti nodi
aumentavano invece di sciogliersi solo
a quel punto io mi osservavo e vedevo
che il mio peso aumentava ma osservavo
mia sorella e la sua leggerezza
camminavamo in centro e incontravamo una
ragazza con Sindrome di Down come lei e
mi faceva anni Mi sa che quella non è
tanto normale Ah io gli dicevo e tu sì
eh Io sì
e ovviamente questa sua risposta era un
altro nodo
i nodi sapete che le cellule del nostro
cervello i neuroni sono paragonati a
nodi il nostro cervello è paragonato a
Noah di reti non solo tantissime
ricerche oggi ci dicono che all'aspetto
il nostro cervello estremamente simile
alle galassie nell'universo non solo che
il numero di neuroni che forme il nostro
cervello è molto molto simile al numero
di stelle osservabili in cielo
l'infinitamente grande e l'infinitamente
piccolo che corrisponde abbiamo un
universo in mente come può non essere un
peso eppure non lo è ad esempio quando
proviamo Gioia quando siamo felici
Ecco oggi mi accorgo di questo con le
persone che si rivolgono a me che mi
chiedono aiuto che l'aggettivo che
utilizzano di più per indicare i loro
pensieri Ad esempio se affetti da
depressione è pesante mi parlano di
mente pesante mi parlano invece di
leggerezza le persone che stanno meglio
e un'altra cosa che noto è che le
persone che mi portano un disagio o
hanno una memoria netta del loro passato
dell'origine del loro disagio oppure non
ricordano assolutamente nulla
che forse pesante leggero a che fare con
la nostra memoria allora per risponderti
vi racconto il mio gioco preferito da
piccolo Io da piccola amavo stare sugli
alberi ma non semplicemente stare ferma
lì ma ogni giorno inventarmi un nuovo
percorso per arrivare più in alto
possibile Insomma mia mamma non mi
cercava tra i prati ma tra le foglie dei
nostri ciliegi e mi accorgevo che per
riuscire a fare questa cosa io dovevo
fare due cose la prima è che quando ero
molto in alto e dovevo liberarmi di ciò
che avevo di superfluo una felpa le
scarpe
La seconda è che quando era arrivata
molto in alto e il ramo dove sarei
dovuto appoggiarmi non avrebbe mai retto
e l'intero mio peso Dovevo cercare altri
punti d'appoggio affidarmi ad altre
fonti d'appoggio una mano più in là un
piede più in qua lasciare andare a
fidarsi
da piccoli è facile vero da grandi un
pochino meno Proviamo a vedere perché
Facciamo un esperimento
Provate a rievocare un ricordo gioioso
qualcosa di piacevole anche di recente
Cominciate a farlo arrivare
pian pianino qualcosa che dove siete
stati bene
un episodio che vi ha reso gioia
sta arrivando
l'ho iniziata a vedere un po' sfocato
per la maggior parte delle persone è
così rimane un po' sfocato anche quella
gioia che avete provato Allora non è
proprio identica adesso ne arrivo carne
vedo rimane sfuggente
Ok adesso
Provate a rievocare un ricordo doloroso
niente di particolarmente traumatico
qualcosa però che vi ha infastidito che
vi ha turbato particolarmente
Cominciate a farla arrivare arriva
e arriva un pochino più nitido un
pochino più netto si vede bene anche
l'emozione che avete provato Arriva
tanto che vorreste scacciarla
ok perché perché accade questo vedete la
nostra memoria è determinata dalle
nostre emozioni e le nostre emozioni
sono fatte di energia ed esattamente
come l'energia sono rappresentabili in
onde allora pensate che le emozioni
positive la gioia la felicità sono
rappresentabili in un piccolo onda molto
alta ma di breve durata perché perché la
gioia finisce subito così noi siamo
portati a ricercare le condizioni che
quella gioia ce l'hanno fatta provare a
riprovarla la gioia le emozioni negative
invece il dolore la tristezza l'angoscia
sono fatti rionde molto più basse molto
più lente e durature perché
perché così noi memorizziamo molto bene
che cosa ci ha fatto male e non andiamo
a riprovarlo
Ecco mia sorella ha da sempre questa
bellissima caratteristica ricorda
nettamente le sue esperienze positive
Ali ti ricordi quando abbiamo visto la
finale di Federer sia anni e mi elenca
tutti i dettagli e lascia andare le cose
negative Ali ti ricordi quando siamo
state male in campeggio no Agne tu
Affida a me ai miei genitori a chi per
lei e ricorda negativo
perché se ci pensiamo bene la leggerezza
non è né nel trasportare a lungo un peso
nel sostenerlo né nel non avere un peso
tanta memoria nessuna memoria ma noi
proviamo il senso di leggerezza il
sollievo quando noi quel peso che stiamo
sostenendo Lo appoggiamo e lo lasciamo
andare
solo lì ci sentiamo leggeri
Allora vogliamo subito provare
Se avete qualcosa che vi piacerebbe
lasciare andare se ve la sentite
Prendetevi per mano
ci volete come volete
saggiate questa consistenza la sentite
pensate che questo è il principale dei
punti d'appoggio con cui riuscirete a
lasciare andare
saluti
[Musica]
[Applauso]